[Music]
in can't let go news submitted by I
should be studying up sorry that's so
hard that he is work leave it alone
a writer discusses whether or not it's
healthy to be a cyberstalking parent
after children grow up and leave the
home oh that's disgusting sexy no the
parent is so control freak
anal lieutenant that they can't just let
their kids be and they gotta like stalk
and like beyond and it just feels like
my dough black mirror episode yeah she
forgot but she was like monitoring her
kids everything through her eyeballs
that's why it's disgusting
my mom does this but in I miss you kind
of way because she watches all of our
videos she wants she looks at all of our
Instagram like it's like a daily routine
she says like she goes off cute that she
watches like a type of video or she
watches like JK news or whatever yeah
and she goes through all the things and
then she's like hey you haven't posting
in a while
I think intent is different that's not
stalking that's what fans do you yeah
exactly she's like a fan of you she's
not like like what's he doing like where
is he going who is this girl and like I
think that that's where it gets it so
interesting cuz I know exactly what
you're talking about is you said well I
think we're so used to having our
parents breathe down our [ __ ] necks
their attention feels annoying do you
want it maybe I don't want it as much as
you guys cuz you I love your mom or I
love my OMA it sound like a nightmare
but then for me it feels more like
neglect and I'm like please hear just
put it this way you know how my mom is
yeah exactly
nobody had one percent of my mom like my
mom she like called me the other day and
then we're having a conversation she
goes so uh I don't see any videos on
your channel what's going on and I'm
like why do you always watch my stuff I
don't understand it but I still want to
hear your voice oh I was like yeah but I
call you like four times a week so per
you talking about as she goes oh and by
the way stop putting your leg up on the
tables in just giving news it's very
disrespectful all the time
all right this conversations over yeah
it's respectful David what the far you
talking about man I never do that yeah
she goes it's still lazy I was like do
you look at Joe she goes he doesn't
count like Casey's parents watches
everything that we do too but that's
different
see when you do the same thing as a fan
and you're just enjoying content it's
different from like what are these what
is he doing where is it going yes for
this friends friends they call you up
and they're like you should you should
an award that shirt it looks disgusting
yes or like they're trying to control
your content and then they're like why
are you acting like that around your
friends or like it's like dude I'm a
grown-ass man don't be telling me what
the [ __ ] to do yeah but what were you
for dinner yeah this writer here like
they were just interviewing families
that have gone through this so for
example this one mom she has twin 19
year old daughters that have recently
moved out of the home to go study and
and so like this mom follows her
daughter's like on everything except
snapchat cuz the girls won't add their
mom on snapchat because they're like I
have to have some privacy like there's
certain things that I want my mom to see
look it's Lutz I don't even want to see
that [ __ ] if I see my [ __ ] son bend
over and jack off your [ __ ] I'm like Oh
what could I witness they're saying like
you know sometimes about and drinking
with friends and dancing like there's
certain things they don't want their mom
to see but this mom here she's very
active like she has notifications turned
on for
and every time there's every time they
do something she immediately likes it
and she'll like comment I love you and
then these girls are texting her like
you could just text me that that's what
I mean she's disgusting yeah do you
think you'll relate one sick freak your
babies are gone and then you're just
like you feel empty because they were so
empty now right yeah and then you got to
get cats or dogs I think oh you have
your you have your partner to balance
that side out
hey you know the stereotype is when the
kids leave the house all the issues that
you had prior to the kid they're it's
gonna come right back so you need some
new hobbies like take some knitting
classes be a part of a book club or do
some other [ __ ] yeah oh is it so funny I
just pictured like us being old and and
kind of going through that you and Jess
again yeah yeah just all of us like all
of us like well we worry like the little
glasses yeah some a spot and then like
doing all people [ __ ] like I don't know
all those things it just a wean in there
I just didn't communicate it's just like
this the words exploded but it's
different though I think like
generationally speaking it's just it's
it's so different now especially because
like the way people have kids today
versus then it's different like my
parents they had kids to give them
everything that they had right so it's
like your legacy continues to live on
and then you want that kid to do better
once I left the house I started making
money my brother is now you know he's a
RN and whatever she feels like that part
of her chapter is complete and now she's
like looking for purpose yeah their
lives was conversely to ours is my whole
existence is for this kid yeah they
didn't have their own purpose exactly so
the difference is that we have purpose
so it's like so it's after they leave I
could get back to my heart
I can start taking BJJ again yeah it's
so funny because it's like now we're
thinking like I want to give this kid
everything but I don't want to lose any
of myself mm-hmm that's like the hard
part that we're balancing right now you
know what I mean and I think for you
guys especially right because you guys
are still building your business you
still have everything that you want to
do but you love this kids so much you
you're trying to figure out both yeah so
I'm pretty sure like when Isaac grows up
and leaves it'll be like oh he's grown
up but I still have Tiffany that I have
to worry about still and you know the
relationship between you and Kate you
think you're gonna stalk them like when
he goes off to college or you think
gonna be like I'm gonna stalk there's
four years go make your mistakes go make
out with dudes get an STD or to get it
to get arrested this is your time to
just wall out you think I give them that
breathing room I think for me I would be
like like go stalking but not like fully
stalking right I wouldn't feel like
these moms that they're talking about in
this article where they're constantly
like commenting liking like you're like
even more creepy just like yeah cuz then
that whatever I'd like to feel to like
yeah my god she's looking at everything
everything I do it's just like she's
suffocating me and I'm not home anywhere
I wouldn't want to do that but I'll
still want to check up on and make sure
he's okay yeah it's like an ex I don't
want them to know I'm looking at their
ship but I'm gonna see like their life
sucks I think it's gonna be really hard
because or it'd be interesting because I
know somebody right now who has a kid
that went off of college like their
relationship with her relationship with
her son is so good
she didn't have to call him he calls her
that's what I'm trying to do you know I
don't want to ever have to check up
hopefully I did a good enough job up to
18 years where he bounces out I don't
want to check up on him but then our
relationships so good that he'll keep
calling me like once a week or twice a
week or whatever exactly and that's what
he does he calls he calls his mom let's
let her know what's going on what he
plans to do next year for like all this
other stuff and so she doesn't really
have to check up on him but for her she
has to learn how to ease up a little bit
because she's so worried like I kind of
like made fun of her the other day cuz
she put up a Facebook post she goes oh
he's out and he's just out there just
it's so dangerous out in the world I was
like he goes to [ __ ] Irvine
alright the safest city in the world
yeah yeah she's what's gonna happen to
him I don't know he's a studdy more we
got a lead sandwich there he's good I
can see myself being one of those
worrywart moms like oh my god is he okay
like does he like who is he hanging out
with but I wouldn't I also think mom's
though they do care a little bit more
than death like just her attachment the
tight goes a little bit different than
mine girls are really good at worrying
like it's it's reality check do you
think mom's worry more about the boys
and they do the girls though because
like mom I feel like she worries way
more about my brother like what's he
doing who's he hanging out with what's
he getting into you know because you are
the person your brother who's the more
capable one in the family you are your
brother definitely me there you go
that's what I was worried more about the
[ __ ] because she my mom worried for me
tremendously I wasn't stupid yeah like
last year and she's like alright I guess
you have a kids
what is it me my mom still worries about
me that I'm probably sure duh
also worries about the universe
exploding we got like so if Isaac had
social media I feel like if I would just
check it and just be like it would ease
my worries I'm gonna go to Isaac's
apartment thank him if you're like hey
so have you been that would be better
for me to just see what he's posting
what if he never posted on social but
what if one of them is like him
spreading us but she's Dan what about
check-in at this point you know what we
should do is go to his like dorm or
apartment and just sit there with
binoculars and then just watch it party
I could see you guys let me get into
that me so fun it's like that weird
balance of like not not judging a young
person so they can be open enough to
tell you what's going on in their life
United mean because like what happens is
like if they [ __ ] up when you judge them
that's when they close up exactly how
this works right and like I know that
theory wise I'm like I get it yeah 100%
I'm on your guys's team but I feel like
once I'm in it I don't know if I own oh
this is all theory this is like well I'm
tell her that [ __ ] I'm like [ __ ] you
got friends being normal and talk to
your [ __ ] friends about your problems
my fight
this is like my ideal world you mean
like good I hope it's a really good game
with great benefit if kids join gangs
now that means they're in it
United mean because it's not cool
anymore yeah if your kids doing the
games if you [ __ ] dope you're
passionate about it yeah I hope so I
hope you dope don't like the top tier
[ __ ] if they don't make a Netflix show
around you you're a little [ __ ] I'll be
tight my kiss are sagging his pants it
just makes it easier for me to spank you
know via in this article you're just
talking about how it's not healthy gay
being like you know so obsessive over
your kids lives that once they leave
home cuz they have to create their own
lives and you have to focus back on
yourself or like your partner yourself a
partner you should focus on that they'll
hate you for it too yeah no just push it
away even more you're not so me to that
social media is addicting you know -
like you almost feel like they're there
with you all the time you know and like
it's hard like your reality starts
shifting I think I think it's easy to
get sucked down into a social media hole
where like you'd forget what's going on
around you yeah I think I'm gonna have a
hard time let it go because I feel like
I'm gonna be one of those guys that
smothers their kids and when they're
like 19 I'm still gonna want to cuddle
them to sleep I was the kid that wanted
to be cuddled to sleep still at 19 and
like cuz I just they just felt like I
yeah like I didn't get enough hugs
cuddling is really cool it's just I
don't like the cuddling when I'm trying
to sleep this more like yeah now it's to
walk away from me cuddle before and then
go in separate beds and play in the same
room so you have a sleepover when
Isaac's 18 Tigers gonna be eight and
then we'll be sending like Isaac off to
college and then tycoon's be standing
here looking at Isaac like all he saw
that's great and we'll be really on
[Music]